all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first question
today hey David will you please do the
right thing and simply denounce outrage
culture so listen the problem is not
outrage
anyone who's paying attention to what is
going on and what has been going on in
society for the last 50 years at least
economically culturally and in many
other ways everything from gross
inequality corporate control of all
aspects of society a government that is
in many ways not held accountable for
its actions the military industrial
complex either the suit aeneas
pseudo-intellectual ism and anti
intellectualism like if you've been
paying attention you should actually be
outraged and that actually makes sense
but the problem is not the outrage
itself in the same way that the problem
with so-called social justice warriors
is not social justice itself and these
words these phrases have become dirty
words in great part because the right
has really successfully focused in on
slivers of movements and blown them up
to be to claim that they are
representative big picture but the the
real issue that I have with quote
outraged culture and some of these other
things the social justice warrior
movement and whatever is not the fact
that they exist but how they are wielded
and I'll even go further and include
identity politics in that I've said
before identity politics in and of
itself as a general concept is not the
problem it's not the problem per se the
problem is that there is a version of
identity politics that has gone beyond
simply recognizing that hey someone's
identity is not only important to them
but one's identity does give them a
unique perspective in terms of their
view of the world and what they can
bring to a conversation and we should
recognize that and listen to that the
problem is there are areas where
identity politics is wielded like a
cudgel I've talked about this before in
the same way outraged outraged meaning
like anger and disapproval of things
outrage helps to change those things if
it is wielded appropriately and
that is what we want if people weren't
outraged about in Justices they'd never
change
the problem is when outrage culture
leads to counterproductive demagoguery
foe activism that's not actually going
to lead to change that the outraged
people claim to want a cartoonish
example is you know the story I did
years ago that went viral on YouTube to
protest racism some white people were
blocked from going to classes one day
that's a totally backwards application
of outrage that we should have about
different forms of systemic racism that
still exists in our society that was not
the right implementation of the outrage
into making productive change in fact it
was completely counterproductive and
then when it comes to media people
should be outraged when discussing the
extremist messages that are perpetuated
but then sometimes people are equally
outraged as they've spoken before just
because someone has the audacity to have
a different point of view that is
destructive outrage culture right when I
say as as a progressive that I want the
us out of Venezuela and our involvement
in Latin America has been disastrous
but that Maduro and Chavez are not
people that have been good for the
Venezuelan people that they have raped
and pillaged the economies and societies
Venezuela all of a sudden I'm an anti
progressive and I am people are quote
outraged at me it's a small sliver again
and that's all we're talking about here
or again I've mentioned this before I
don't see Tulsi Gabbard as the
be-all-end-all presidential candidate
that every progressive should support
Wow all of a sudden I am the enemy of
the progressive movement people are
demanding this that the other thing from
me or because I think the squad lacks
political savvy and sometimes misses the
forest for the trees outrage because I
am now the enemy outraged there and of
course I'm biased because it relates to
me that outrage seems out of place and
literally counter to the 95 or 99
percent of issues on which we all agree
and should be activists for so the
problems with all of these movements the
problems are not
the outrage itself or the social justice
or the recognition of identity in people
it's their application and their
implementation and I'll say something
further corporate media takes advantage
of these rifts corporate media exploits
them and makes them bigger and makes
profit off of them
while they divide people and prevent
actual progress so we help them to
divide us the more we participate in
these battles around some of these
issues understand outrage culture
understand why people should be outraged
and wield these ideas in a responsible
way and most people do I know I say this
often most people actually do and most
people recognize identity for the value
that it has and they recognize social
justice for what it is that we want it
to be and we have to make sure that we
don't allow that sliver that doesn't or
the agent the agent provocateur Ozma's
provocateur who are trying to just
agitate using a fake outrage or fake
social justice warrior personas or
whatever and focus on the fact that most
of us are united as to what it is that
we want to see going forward if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something
you already love or you can get ahead in
your career by learning new skills that
will help you at your job I've gotten a
ton out of it Pat has taken some courses
that he's found really valuable and I
think you'll love it to get started for
free by clicking the link under this
video